[Music]
[Applause]
if you listen to this show you know that
i
have mentioned occasionally that i
try to get people into a hall of fame
you know john fasenda i reached out to
the hall of fame and i said the voice of
the nfl should be in the hall of fame
and he got in now i've lobbied for other
players to get into the hall of fame and
i had never met tony beselli years ago
i'd never met him but i did watch him
and i you know it's one of those where
you say who's a hall of famer when you
watch somebody you go i think he's a
hall of famer he was all pro lineman uh
you know back in the 1995 draft
and
you know linemen sort of get forgotten
because we only bring their name up if
they do something like holding or they
you know give up a sack
and i just saw tony and and said the
jags have one of the better offensive
linemen that i've ever seen and that's
saying a lot because i've been around
the game for you know what 40 years now
and i i didn't even know that when the
announcement happened but i got all
these people who sent me texts and said
your boy got the hall of fame and i go
who's my boy and then i realized that
tony got into the hall of fame and uh
we've brought it up uh numerous times
usually you know on this day or the day
you know days after you don't get into
the hall of fame and tony got into the
hall of fame so i was very very happy
and i said to fritz see if tony can join
us and uh tony congrats we did it
well dan we did i'm glad i'm your boy
too i mean that's uh
that put it that made me laugh this
morning
uh yeah it was uh this is much better
than the last i think uh this is my
sixth year so the last five years before
where i'm mourning with you about not
making the hall of fame so it's uh
i've enjoyed this super bowl weekend as
uh as much as any weekend i ever have
and uh it was a lot of fun
walk us through how you find out you're
a hall of famer
yeah you know because of cope with the
last two you know in that past they used
to vote on saturday before the super
bowl and then you'd find out saturday
night the honor show um the last few
years because of the pandemic they voted
virtually this year they did it on the
18th
and i had no idea when i'd find out and
my wife found out on the 19th the hall
of fame called her and said hey your
husband's made the hall of fame and she
didn't tell me because they wanted to
set up this oh did not tell me that she
was they want to set up this big
surprise knock
and so on the 27th you know i'm sitting
around waiting i haven't heard anything
nobody's talking and uh i'm at a buddy's
house one of my good friends uh
and
we're they're talking they set up this
whole ruse to get me there first of all
and then there's a knock on the door and
he goes hey can you go get that for me
uh i got to do something and i said sure
i'll go get it so i walk downstairs i
open up the door and there's anthony
munoz in
his gold jacket
with the nfl network and hall of fame
and all my family behind them and you
know he gives puts his hand out shakes
my hand gives me a big hug he says
welcome
to the pro football hall of fame so that
i mean it was just
it was magical
um
but then i couldn't say anything for two
weeks like we were sworn to science
and so like there's a moment it's like
you forget i don't see you forget about
it but i'm like can they call me and
like take this back i mean it's not
nothing's out there
so the big the big moment was walking uh
on the honors when they called me out uh
bruce smith was one introduced me which
is uh pretty a fitting base seeing that
the game against him was kind of my
coming out party
um that's when it was like okay
they're never taking this away now
what kind of emotions
um oh i think the the like the
prevailing emotion is gratitude more
than anything like it's so it's so
humbling because now i'm a huge i've
been a football fan since i can remember
so a lot of the guys that are in hall of
fame those are the guys i looked up to i
want like you watched and i wanted to be
like and i never imagined
that my name would be next to theirs or
i'd have a bus next to theirs
um and so it's really humbling but just
the gratitude i feel for
all the people that helped me get here
because you know football number one is
the greatest team sport ever and and i
played the greatest team position
uh there's no great i mean you were
dependent on the guys next year as an
offensive lineman
and so and i have great coaches and
mentors and
um and so i'm just really thankful for
that you know
i always say a couple things i didn't
make myself six seven you know
that was the gift of god who said i'm
gonna make you big and give you good
feet and then i'm thankful that god for
great people in my path because i just
don't think any of us get where we go by
ourselves
and uh i had some really great people
and uh and then the the one like it
wasn't it wasn't a
bad thing but there was a sad moment my
dad was my dad passed away in 2021
and uh i knew last year when they called
me and said i didn't make it there was a
good chance he wouldn't be around
because he had cancer when i got in and
so
missing him being there and him
experiencing it because i don't think
there was a bigger fan of mine than my
dad
and uh just what he meant in my life so
i missed him but i know he was up in
heaven smiling probably doing high fives
and uh enjoying himself
talking to tony biselli the uh former
jacksonville jaguar tackle and first
player drafted by the jags is that is
that right you were the first player
yeah that's right okay yep
um
how would uh tony beselli and his prime
have done against aaron donald what
would you have done last night against
him
yeah after i would pray a lot before i
went out there
because it aired up the eredaw reminds
me of uh
you know he uh
with this the the way he plays in his
size you know he he gives a big guy like
me problems in one sense because he's
he's just he has instant leverage
and reminds me of john randall a little
bit his ability to get on top and
overpower but also his quickness
and so i and i've watched aaron donald a
lot and he's one of the top defensive
players ever to play this game if he
never plays another snap just like he's
like one of those guys like brady and
some others just like wave the five
years just put them in the dang hall of
fame i mean that's where they belong
um but i i watched him i watched him a
bunch and i would one thing i would do
is i'd force aaron donald to run over me
because if he because he's so quick and
i think what you want to do is make sure
you don't get beat right away
like you want to make it as long and
give your quarterback as much time and
make him go through you
uh because like even though play at the
end of the game he got up got up field
on the shoulder of uh
spleen and got around the corner there's
no chance you've got to force them to go
around it's easier said that so i just
sit off of them they just said hey all
right aaron if you're going to get sacks
today you're going to go right through
me
because i'm not going to i'm not going
to sit right down the line of scrimmage
let you beat me immediately he's just a
fabulous player he's one of the few you
know every great defense alignment every
great pass rusher
you have to have speed and power i just
don't think you can just beat you know
good offense alignment with one if you
just have one in your arsenal and aaron
donald has it all
where do you think it turned last night
for the bengals
um you know it was
i'll say before i answer this it was the
least watched super bowl i've ever
watched man because i was enjoying the
moment so much
about the hall of fame in the suite and
having a good time
so this might not be my best work
[Laughter]
i you know i thought i thought when they
settled for some field goals in that
tight red red zone i think that's that
would hurt them um
and
i was shocked at the end in the two
minutes that they get in the shotgun
you need you need a half a yard
i mean get up there and take your
chances i mean
that will that shocked me i mean that's
not why they lost the game i mean they
felt like that was their best chance but
the red zone production and then also
just you know i i don't understand why
teams under a yard are getting the
shotgun and throwing the ball i mean if
you can't get half a yard you probably
don't deserve to win
congratulations and uh long time coming
but you know i wish your father could
have been there for you i'm sure that
you'll uh acknowledge that in your
speech and we look forward to hearing
that
dan i appreciate it i do appreciate all
the support of you and the show and all
the guys on the show throughout the
years that is not lost on me and i
appreciate it greatly thank you bud we
appreciate your time that's uh tony
beceli now call him a hall of famer